if a person has gold or silver jewelry
which they intend to use do they have to
pay zakat on that as far as paying zakat
on gold and silver jewelry if a person
is using it they difference
opinion one group of Scholars say that
zakat need not be given while the other
group of Scholars say that zakat should
be given according to the
scholars like uh Imam Malik Imam Shafi
and Amed H may Allah have mercy on them
all of them say that zakat need not be
given on gold and silver jewelry if it
being use based on the Hadith of Al
where ja Abdullah may Allah when you has
asked that is zakat liable on gold and
silver jewelry if it is being used he
said that zakat is not liable even if
it's a thousand
dinar th000 dinar worth of gold zakat is
not liable it's mentioned of that
asak the daughter of with him she used
to put jewelry on her children on her
daughters and the jewelry was more than
50,000
dinar of gold but yet she never used to
pay zakat and another Hadith which is
mentioned in M Malik that a pleas with
her the wife of the Prophet she used to
take care of Hanes who wore gold jewelry
but she never paid Zak on that so based
on this Hadith all the Hadi say based on
these three hadiths and other some
Hadith that these Scholars say that
zakat need not be given but the other
group of Scholars like
Abu have mercy on them these group of
Scholars they say that zakat should be
given on gold jewelry even if it's wor
and they give various of the Quran and
the Hadi for example Allah says in the
Quran in Surah TBA chapter number 9
verse number 34 and 35 that as to those
who hold gold and silver and spend it
not in the way of Allah subhana wa tala
meaning those who don't give zakat
announc to them a grievous penalty and
that wealth will be heed in the fire of
hell and with that they'll be branded on
the forehead on the flanks and on the
back and it will be told to them that
have the taste of wealth that you hold
Ed so here it says that anyone does not
give zakat on gold and silver hold it
and don't give zakat you'll ban with
fire So based on this ver of the Quran
they say irrespective whether using it
or not you have to pay zakat and theth
of wasallam in s Muslim number two in
the book of zakat Hadith number
2161 that all those who hold gold and
silver and spend it on in the way of
Allah subhana wa t ta'ala a plate of
fire would be made on the day
and they would be heated in the Hellfire
and with them they would be branded on
the flanks on the forehead and On The
Backs and then he recited the verse of
the Quran of Surah Al Imran CH 3: 180
that those do not spend in the way of
Allah subhana
tala and
further there is a Hadith of M wasallam
which is mentioned in Sun Abu da
number two in the book of zakat Hadith
number
1558 where a lady comes along with her
daughter wearing two heavy Bangles of
gold and when they approach the Prophet
The Prophet asked that have you paid
zakat on that so they said no so the
prophet said that do you want Allah
subhanahu wa taala to put Bangles of
fire around your
hands so immediately that lady she
removes The Bangles and giv to the
prophet and says I give it in the way of
Allah and
his there another Hadith mentioned in
Abu da number two in the book of zakat
number
1560 with her wife of the Prophet one
day she wears two rings of silver and
the prophet enters and sees these two
rings of silver so he asked her what is
this so she says that I made myself for
you a messenger of Allah
so the prophet asked her that did you
pay zakat so she says no or as Allah
Wills so Prophet replies that is
sufficient for you to take you to Hell
Fire So based on this Hadith the
scholars say that zakat is f on the
jewelry even if it's w if it contains
gold and silver and the second ruling of
the scholars that Zak is f is more
stronger and is more
correct though they differ opinion but
that is more followed by the
people and because better give zakat
rather than stay away from it it all
will get Saab in that therefore most of
the scholars agree in the second view
though the scholars do defer among the
scholars who say Zak is not F on gold
and silver jewelry is jab Abdullah
Abdullah Omar Asma Abu
Bakr be pleased with them all Imam Malik
Imam Shafi IM may Allah have mercy on
them these Scholars say that zakat is
not F the other group of scholar say
zakat is f amongst them we
have with him
Abdullah
Abdullah Bin
Abbas we have sufyan t m be pleased with
them all IM Abu
hanifah may Allah have mercy on
himam may Allah have mercy on them
Alli binas may Allah have mercy on them
all so all these Scholars they say that
zakat is f on gold jewelry if it reaches
the if it doesn't reach it's not F and
the second view that is f is more
authentic it's more stronger but there
different opinion among the scholars